some questions from the mailbag shireen
this one comes from at
arizo ballager i always have to make
sure that it isn't something
inappropriate that is hiding in that
handle i don't think i don't think it is
how can the eagles be saved it's
depressing watching this team
wow uh i think uh well i think the best
thing they have going for is they play
in the nfc east i mean one-on-one leads
it and the giants lost saquon they're
right in the hunt for the nfc east title
despite their record so far but
serious concerns about that offense
their defense has been good enough they
ranked 9th in total defense but that
offense is 27th and carson wentz his
passer rating it's 33rd in the nfl yes
there are only 32 starting quarterbacks
that includes both quarterbacks starting
for the chargers have been better than
carson wentz has been this year he has
not been good two touchdowns four
interceptions so far he has to be better
and i realize look when you look at that
team i don't like the talent that he has
working with him i've said that i
thought they should have gone out and
added some other pieces he's got two
really good tight ends and what else i
don't see a whole lot there that scares
me on offense but he's still got to go
out and make plays and be special if
this team is going to win
yeah i agree with you completely they
they are fortunate that they're in the
nfc east where
being 0-2 out of the gates isn't
necessarily a disaster because
there's another 0-2 team and there's two
one-on-one teams and they're still in it
and they like to dig a hole and climb
out of it they've done that each of the
last two years we see them find some
resilience and some will and some
determination later in the year but you
know the injuries continue to be an
issue carson wentz less effective this
year than last year and uh
yesterday was it was an eye-opener i
thought the rams would go there and win
but i didn't think it would be as
convincing as it was and they can only
be grateful that there weren't fans
there to actually make their feelings
known about the way the eagles have been
performing of late but there's plenty of
time for them to turn it around uh
apparently there was some booing that
was uh piped through the the broadcast
but i doubt that there was actual booing
that was heard in the stadium it's that
constant 70 no fake batteries either
background noise no fake batteries no
fake snowballs although we'll see we'll
see maybe they'll have maybe they'll
have like some sort of a of a snowball
machine in december uh to simulate what
the fans would be doing if they were
actually there especially if the season
continues the way it has for the
philadelphia eagles all right the
atlanta falcons are the focus of the
next question at a powell 83 wednesday
and quinn getting fired now
arthur blank the owner of the team
has been
very supportive i thought last year
during the bye week it would be
literally goodbye to dan quinn they had
one win they finished six and two down
the stretch he got a chance to come back
but now i'll tell you what and sharing i
haven't seen the actual quotes but we
have the text chain where the various
writers at pft say i'm going to take
this story i'm going to take that story
apparently josh albert will be posting a
story that arthur blank doesn't think
his players understood the on-site kick
rule which is not
a ringing endorsement of dan quinn who
said yesterday that they do understand
the onside kick rule and if you remember
the play yesterday that spinning ball
the players just watched it they were
waiting for it i think to not make it 10
yards instead of jumping on the damn
thing so if blank is contradicting quinn
that's not a good sign and when you look
at the schedule this year they have a
later buy than last year and they have
some opportunities to win they play the
panthers twice before the buy but
there's a buy that is out there for week
10
and that would be the sweet spot and
they've got multiple former coaches on
staff who could take over rahim morris
is the defensive coordinator although
the defense stinks dirk cutter is the
offensive coordinator he didn't do well
as the head coach in tampa then again
neither did raheem morris but at least
the offense is the the bright spot on
that team so that week 10 is when we
need to watch uh shireen for uh for dan
quinn to be out if it happens this year
well i was surprised that dan quinn got
a sixth year in atlanta i mean he hasn't
been to the playoffs in a couple years
and and they've really struggled and
they we know they've lost leads it's
been since the super bowl we all
remember
the lead they had that they lost and
they've really struggled since then so i
was surprised they brought him back in
the first place and now you wonder how
long he will last after the last couple
of games that they've had he's now 43
and 39 at atlanta to me the most damning
thing that's happened with dan quinn
atlanta he he's supposed to be this
defensive guru and yet his defense in
atlanta is never ranked in the top 10.
that to me is the worst thing that has
happened in atlanta so far
and what arthur blank has seen along the
way is kyle shanahan who maybe should
have been hired to be the head coach
instead of a defensive guy see that's a
problem you hire a defensive coach end
up with a good offense you lose your
offensive coordinator you got to go find
another offensive coordinator and that
offensive coordinator may not be very
good now at least the falcons offense is
good they need to get the defense better
quick preview of the first game played
by the raiders in las vegas the saints
come to town to play in the roomba the
death roomba uh who do you like i i
assume you like the saints tell me tell
me you like the scene oh yeah yeah you
gotta like the saints i just wish we had
the black hole there i wish we could see
that but yeah the saints are gonna win
this one but i'm looking forward to this
game i'm excited by it
yeah and hey we don't know at this point
how good any team is how bad any team is
or maybe the raiders can surprise them
the saints don't have michael thomas are
going to have to be creative with some
of these other guys i want to see more
taysom hill than i saw last week we saw
a lot less of hill in week one than we
did in the playoff game they need to use
him more they need to get creative with
the slot and they'll be fine i think the
saints win that game and we'll be back
tomorrow to talk about that game if
there's anything left to talk about at 5
p.m eastern thanks for joining us enjoy
the game tonight we'll see you in the
morning for pft live
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports